[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the chief
political correspondent at the guardian
jessica elgot and the whitetail editor
at the financial times sebastian payne
jessica joining us very shortly
sebastian good to see you so let's uh
see what's on the front pages then
russians give up on conquest of kiev is
on the front of the telegraph as moscow
redeploys troops away from the capital
citing efforts to build trust in peace
talks
but the metro describes it as russian
roulette as the u.s urges people to be
clear-eyed about what is happening on
the ground
the times also looks at the u.s and
britain's doubts over the kremlin's
intentions
the queen of broken hearts is on the
front page of the sun as her majesty
remembered her husband prince philip at
his memorial service
the pain and the stain is the mirror's
headline highlighting prince andrew's
appearance at the queen's side weeks
after he paid millions to settle a
sexual abuse lawsuit
the express says the queen's decision to
allow him to escort her
sparked tensions within the royal family
the financial times leads on disputes
between russia and the eu as moscow
insists that gas exports are paid in
rubles
to prop up the currency
the eye reporting that the prime
minister still does not accept lockdown
laws were broken at number 10 despite 20
fines being issued to staff by police
that is also the story for the guardian
which says mr johnson faces a renewed
threat to his position
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
so we're joined then by jessica elgot
and sebastian payne she looks round
hoping jessica's there she is yes well
done um wi-fi issues once again anyway
great to see both of you but let's kick
off shall we with those peace talks that
we saw today between russia and uh
ukraine and sebastian with this uh
promise by the russians
to drastically reduce combat operations
around both the capital and the northern
city of chernhiv and the reaction to
that
so nobody wants to get ahead of
themselves here because obviously we've
heard a lot of propaganda from moscow
about its intentions in ukraine and it's
hard to know whether this is actually
true is it is it really pulling back
operations or is it in fact just saying
that while redeploying troops to
different parts of ukraine but we do
know that bit by bit those negotiations
are starting to edge towards some kind
of conclusion that could lead to a cease
fire the problem though is any kind of
settlement is going to have to result in
some part of ukraine as disputed
territory at best and that's incredibly
hard for president zielinski to sell to
his people and the outlines you can
imagine would be that there'd be uh the
eastern part of ukraine would be at best
disputed territory this would go to a
referendum there will be security
guarantees to ensure that um
and russia doesn't invade again they'd
probably be backed up with support from
the uk from france and germany there may
also be the option for ukraine to join
the eu but it would have to take
neutrality from nato and on all military
matters so those talks seem to be
heading towards something everyone
obviously hopes and desperately wants
there to be as some kind of ceasefire
but
and the uk has been particularly
skeptical about is this the reality of
what's going on here and boyce johnson
has described this offer and the
suggestion from russia that they are and
pulling troops back from kiev um as
twisting the knife in an open wounds
that gives you the idea of what the uk
is feels here and we also know that the
wagner group which is a good military um
uh personnel who are deployed by the
kremlin across the world they are
brought a thousand troops into ukraine
so it's a very messy picture it's not as
if this thing is coming to a conclusion
there's no obvious solution here but
there are tentative signs that we could
be heading towards a ceasefire which
given the last three or four weeks of
suffering would be very welcome by all
but of course you know obviously russia
is the aggression here and the uk in
particular does not want to seem to be
rewarding it and i think again on the
front page of the times its concerns in
westminster that and boyce johnson fears
france and germany may in fact allow
land to be given away to us or just to
get a ceasefire that's not a place
president zielenski wants it's not a
place the uk wants to be either yes
you've certainly outlined the issues for
the future um but jessica back to the
immediate term uh the us and if we look
at the metro in fact you know it's
russian roulette the u.s warning don't
be fooled by moscow's move there's
there's a there's a deep lack of trust
in anything that russia says um the u.s
saying it's not a withdrawal it's a
redeployment um but militarily does this
mean
actually we should accept that they they
feel they are overstretched that they
can't take kiev that the ukrainians are
pushing back in places like urban this
northwest settlement or northwest of
kiev rather and actually it's an
admission of failure by the russians
i think that's probably you know a good
reading of the scenario that the
pentagon seems to suggest that there has
they they have witnessed some movement
by some russian units away from kiev in
the last day or so but they think it's
small numbers and they think it's
essentially a repositioning not not a
major withdrawal and then we should all
be prepared to watch for a major
offensive against other areas of ukraine
uh potentially to show that the russians
are seriously you know committed to
taking territory elsewhere i mean it it
is also as he as you say you know kind
of an acknowledgement of what the
situation is about where the advance has
been stalling for weeks and ukrainian
forces have had some recent successes in
in taking back territory and russia
doesn't seem to have the forces to be
able to encircle the city in the way
that it originally intended so you know
obviously that's you know there's some
parts of that which are positive and but
i think you know it's probably right and
you hear skepticism in london and in
washington about the terms of the these
peace negotiations and how much they are
actually progressing
and the meantime um if we go to the
business section of the telegraph
sebastian uh yacht seizing continues uh
this time in the uk
yes there's a picture of graham chaps
who's acquiring himself a new toy today
which is a
36 million pound super yacht that has
been impounded by the government you see
pictured there in london and there's
been some suggestions on twitter this
could be a nice jubilee present for the
queen and make up for the new royal
yacht there but this is an example of
the government trying to pursue those
sanctions and those frozen assets and
make sure that they are within the
government's control that and i can
imagine we'll see a lot more of this in
terms of properties in terms of boats
but uh it's a very good visual and i
have to say when i saw the picture of
that yacht i thought was rather
ostentatious and i was not a particular
fan of the color scheme they've got
there but at least it seems to match
grand chaps's tie and i think that you
know there's a lot of reports coming out
from these oligarchs who've had their
assets seized and some of them are
claiming that they can now not do
anything they can't work they can't
travel all they have is the roof above
their head because everything else is
totally frozen and if we flip this back
to what it means for the situation in
ukraine again there's some fears in
whitehall that what could happen is if
there is a ceasefire and if russia
agrees to take no more land then some
european countries might want to ease
back sanctions immediately because of
course they're having a huge economic
effect on the whole of um the west's
economy and that would obviously be a
pretty dangerous thing to do because
it's saying to russia where you've taken
some land you've had a temporary hit but
then in fact you know you've got that
new land and and and and and your
sanctions are getting pulled back so the
uk is still very much at the forefront
of this and the forefront of being as
tough as possible and i imagine no
matter what happens with other countries
they'll keep seizing yachts and keep
seizing properties and using this a very
visual example of the fight against the
putin regime uh the transport secretary
saying the detention a clear and stark
warning to putin and its cronies and his
cronies rather the ft they're reporting
that the yacht is ultimately owned by a
little known businessman
businessman who's at odds with the
russian state over a tax evasion
investigation so we'll have to see what
happens with the with the photo
opportunity of mr shaps there in the
meantime two domestic matters and to the
guardian um jessica uh law breaking in
number ten um this is this is an article
partly written by you as well so talk us
through um what we finally learned uh in
terms of partygate
we have finally learned something which
which you know should sound
extraordinary but something that we've
kind of become um just just normalized
in the past few months is that there
were there was law breaking in the heart
of downing street that people who set
the rules or amongst those who
communicated the rules to the general
public which
meant that people took enormous
sacrifices and to stay indoors not to
meet up with their loved ones during
during the pandemic and which we were
told were essential to save lives that
the rules were broken so egregiously in
downing street that the metropolitan
police have decided that they that they
merit being issued a fine and that's 20
people and we're told it's the first
tranche now you know just to step back a
minute that is quite that is quite an
extraordinary moment and yes there are
lots of things that we still don't know
we still don't know if boris johnson is
going to be issued with a fine himself
and we know that the metropolitan police
looking at six events which he's said to
have attended and we know that there are
you know these are supposed to be the
cases or what we're told these are the
cases that are most straightforward so
there will have been it was intimated to
me people who just copped it and said
yeah i you know give me a fine i admit
it and i don't want to drag this on
and so therefore that you know it could
easily be that number of people who
you know the evidence is just so
overwhelming that they invited people to
the parties or that they admitted being
at the parties that they can just issue
the fines but the prime minister is
contesting it so you wouldn't expect
necessarily for him to be among the
earliest of those who are issued a fine
and talking to tory mps today especially
the real you know those ones who have a
bit more rebelliously inclined and
it's a start of a job for them to stop
convincing people that it is still the
right thing to do for the prime minister
to go
and it starts with saying that because
there was law breaking in downing street
the prime minister's denials and his
insistence that the guidance was
followed at all times means that he has
essentially lied to the house of commons
boris johnson you know denies all of
that says he didn't says he was misled
or whatever and has apologized for
attending at least one of the events but
only one of them as far as
i'm aware um and we'll see how you know
he manages to get around any any sort of
further accusations you know against his
senior staff and himself yes i mean that
all that theme is picked up by the eye
isn't it the pm is in denial the paper
says over number 10 party fines what
does he do about it the convention is i
guess you lie to parliament you go he's
not so fond of conventions will he write
this one out sebastian
you certainly try and ride it out and uh
i think we've seen those clips shed
endlessly on social media today of boris
johnson saying in december guidance was
followed at all times when now we know
that that was not true because the men
have issued these 20 fines and as
jessica said we don't know who to they
could be 20 different people they could
be a smaller number of people getting
multiple fines again all this is
incredibly unclear but i think the fact
is is that this is coming to a head
pretty soon for boris johnson and if he
is personally fined he is in grave
political trouble because it simply
means the met believes the prime
minister would have conducted criminal
activity and that's as simple as that he
would have broken the law and i think
you can strip away all the politics at
that point and just say that it comes a
very difficult situation for the prime
minister but if he doesn't get fined
then essentially he'll be one hop and
three is how people in number 10 siege
and he will do another mia culpa he'll
apologize for the behavior of those
around him probably institute some kind
of alcohol ban within downing street but
i think this question about has he lied
or has he misled well the key thing that
and the prime minister says the
parliament was there were no parties you
know but defining a party is very
difficult as far as your you and i are
concerned jessica this could be a party
right now and no one could want to sort
of exactly put a definition to that so
boris johnson is is obviously the words
he's used in parliament are very careful
and obviously the sentiment and the tone
of what he said may not have been
straightforward but was it
straightforward lied then i think that's
much more difficult but i think tory mps
are just very much in a wait and see um
place at the moment if he doesn't get
fined it's much less dangerous if he
does then it's very powerless
apologies for rushing you just want to
show the mac cartoon as well front page
of the telegraph it looks like uh
partying coppers actually delivering
their party fines delivered with a rush
of them and some balloons party here i
don't know i'm on matad apart from the
floor manager so there we are um
anyway maybe it is
i stayed there lots more still to come
including the pain and the stain
controversy as prince andrew accompanies
the queen to a service commemorating
prince philip
[Music]
welcome back to watching the press
preview
with me now the chief political
correspondent at the guardian jessica l
gotten the white hall editor at the
financial time sebastian payne welcome
back to both of you um and jessica for
very many people it would be wonderful
to see the queen today even though the
occasion itself was obviously incredibly
sad not least for her
if we take a look at a number of the
newspapers including the daily mirror
yes and and seeing that picture of the
queen i mean she that the look of
devastation on his on her face will you
know will touch anyone especially anyone
who's lost
um a partner or lost someone close to
them i mean yeah anything that helps
prince andrew rehabilitate his
reputation is something that i would
bulk at but on on the other hand
you know having her child next to her at
that moment of grief feel it feels harsh
to try and deny anybody that and he um
you know prince andrew is the second son
of the man being remembered of course uh
daily mail picks up on that though
royals dismay at andrew's role taking
center stage in the philipp memorial
service um sebastian i don't know what
your paper feels about it
the ft tends to not have too many views
on royal matters i have to say but my
personal view on this thing that it was
such a great shame and disaster to have
the duke of york there and there's
reports on the mail and other papers
that he um has split the royals with
charles and william being quite unhappy
at the fact he was there you know this
is a man who's out to settle our most
unbelievable sum of money with someone
who's accused him of those awful crimes
and the fact that he was at the front
and center of the queen's first major
public appearance in six months i think
it was a big misstep and again we all
know for a long time that prince andrew
has been described as the queen's
favorite son and that may be the case
but i think in today's service which was
absolutely beautiful and it was very
wonderful to see the queen out and about
again this was a mistake and he
shouldn't have been then if he was there
he should have been in the shadows not
putting himself front and center
sebastian payne from the ft jessica
algot from the guardian thank you both
very much indeed thank you